hi my name is Emmanuel Garces I work for
Wolfram and I do Geographic
visualization functions today we're
going to talk about that
the talk will cover a survey to the data
we have including vectors and to the
functions we have developed through
surveys that day
hello my name is Emily Garces we'll be
talking about Geographic visualization
eyewall for I work for the visualization
team with Brett and the rest of the team
okay yeah
the talk is mainly I focus it on how
data is going to give us the deformation
to feed the nine piece of legislation
functions for Geographics I mean we
already have nine of them so we
essentially have three different types
of data new position or geo entities
with a position your position and
entities video position associated with
values and vectors so there is also a
twitch talk here's a link I will upload
this to the table so you will be able to
see the street stock okay the first of
the you referred graphical data we have
is new position or entities we start by
showing how can we use this kind of data
by using geo list plot that is
essentially the Geo version of this plot
so we can feed Julie's plot with
entities like say the Kobe desert or
using a Geo variant of the United States
showing all the areas or just random
with a random video position right so he
here we are showing points for those
Lagoo positions or gobi desert right and
showing a polygon for the united states
so we can mix different kind of inputs
typical example of using yoli's plot is
showing points on a map like the highest
30 new york city buildings
so in this case you can see we can use
Wolfram Alpha input so you know this
plot and basically all of the graphical
visualization functions except this kind
of inputs write another function we can
use by filling it with inputs that are
due positions or entities is your
historian here we're showing a histogram
of 300 randomly positioned on Australia
right and we are using the default
meaning it's an hexagon string we can
set different bit specifications like an
administrative division showing us how
many points are in each of those
divisions or we can use different bins
like triangles or rectangles there are
more different specifications for bins
but that will will not it was we have
not got not enough time for that right
okay
of course we can use data from Wolfram
Alpha if I click here you can see the
interpretation of this ok so we are
basically using the parser form warfare
of right so here we are we are showing
the largest tank 100 cities in the
United States as you can see there are a
lot of series right here but probably
not with the same population right so
later we will show how we can use your
historian with positions associated with
values in this case population
okay
who can specify different pin as I told
this case we are using the US state or
probably a zip code for the terrace top
city buildings in New York right so
[Music]
basically that's your history what do
you history on those four inputs having
entities or your positions okay we have
a continuous version of your history and
that's just good history it's
essentially based on the smooth kernel
distribution of data in this case we are
showing the same input without for
historian now we are showing the 300
random positions in Australia the same
for the cities in the USA you can see
that the density of series I mean of
positional cities are in those two parts
right we are not using population yet as
you can see yeah we will use both
history has different settings one of
them is changing the bandwidth of the
smooth gradual distribution or using
different methods for calculating those
bandwidth and so on okay and as you can
see the plot goes inside the ocean so we
can specify this region we want to
include in the plot so we are
restricting constraining the radium
function to the United States right okay
yeah yeah okay the second kind of data
is your position or entities associated
to values of course those entities have
to have the property position because we
want to relate a position or a
coordinate to a value so the first
function I'm showing here is your region
value plot and I'm plotting well
different countries and some value right
and the value is coloured by using some
color function we can also use
quantities or as you can see you can use
Wolfram Alpha input so we are
associating as it is sitting again
entities with quantities in this case
those are the exports of oil of each of
those countries another way to visualize
this kind of data is by using geo bubble
chart and you will chart as you can see
shows bubbles whose size or whose area
well by the way we can set it to be
proportional to the area or the radius
of the bubble so we can see each bubble
is proportional to each value associated
to each coordinate right okay so the
bubbles can be any anything as long as
we can see how proportional those but
bubble size are in this case we are
plotting the same countries we showed
earlier
but we are showing a budget by a chart
comparing the oil consumption
I mean the the size of the bubble is the
oil consumption and the the yellow area
is the what's it yeah
the blue area is the production so in
Japan they don't have that much
production but have a lot of consumption
right okay so you can see the sizes are
very different in China we have to have
half sir off okay
wait I think I got into the yeah my yeah
okay we are back to do history but now
we are using coordinates as stated with
values in this case we are now
associating the top 100 cities of the
USA with their population now we are
using with the data we can use many kind
of different specification for the input
in this case were using weighted data
now we can see that the population in
this area is not that weak as a
population in this area right in the
other use of your historian we saw that
we had a lot of cities here but we if we
add up all of the population we have
more people here right ok so there are
some input inputs that doesn't make
sense right for you history will get the
data say for instance if we want to try
to make the same for the highest 30 New
York City buildings we got something
strange right because we are adding up
the height of each field in between and
unless you want to have a measure of how
many concrete are there or I don't know
yeah but we can do that okay we are
backing into juice Moo's histogram but
now using the Associated data to
coordinates so in this case you can see
that if ya effectively we have more
people here right
okay we can also use the rim function
and there are what is coming next we
have using C to plot and I have put this
here because it also accepts positions
associated with values so geo density
plot is the Geo version for the city
plot in this case I'm showing an example
showing the zone in the in the world as
you can see well that's this one is
correctly right wait because he is here
we have we have agitated heights to the
currents of the opposition so we are
assuming that this object have
coordinates and its coordinate have
height asset we know that ozone is not a
height but we can deal with that
it's a height okay here's the the plot
we just have to say type J density plot
of of this object and of course we can
apply different settings for it and have
this nice view of how they also on wise
and that particularly that I don't
remember the date okay
[Music]
as I said we can use yo elevation
objects with some Heights specified
inside the object as we can see we have
the height bounds here and this is the
elevations for here - like in Oregon so
we're using density plot to show how
those elevations look like
okay ready wait this line here is very
trip I think so that that's that that's
new in the in the new geoserver so we
didn't have that before if you just
asked what this line is doing here right
yeah sure sure it is okay yeah yeah we
can use that but setting the plot
legends goes to two automatic yeah yeah
we can do that and of course we can
change the color function scales and so
on okay
here comes Joe contour plot Geo control
plot is also coming soon it's
essentially the the same that we do for
your density plot but we are showing
that you know the contours as we have
for least counter plot in this case I'm
just using okay this shouldn't be here
but okay I have a Eurasian z-- and the
same crater-like example so as you can
see we are showing the elevation of each
contour and here we have nothing right
but what happens if we change the number
of contours
as well as the data we have is has a
really good level of zoom we can see
that we have some let's say regularities
inside there like so we can go further
in more detail for the contours to to be
shown right now but by default we don't
have any shading here but we can set
that up so in this case we are using a
shading of course each color depends on
the color function and the value right
and as I said we can change the the
color function so those are basically
the functions that uses our entity or a
new position associated to a value right
but we have a third kind of okay before
going to that a as I said with the
buildings example we have to be wise
about choosing what function to use
right because we can imagine a New York
like each building being an elevation or
a mountain or something probably that
could be interesting
somehow I am Not sure but anyway we have
new functions and we have data and we
can experiment by just feeding that date
that they run into the new functions and
see what does look like and if it's
interesting for us right okay now yeah
the third kind of data we we have our
geography vectors okay we have the first
function that uses that data is your
vector plot G vector plot essentially
takes a Geo vector object like this one
here I'm just making Association of
random geo position objects in Europe to
a random vector consisting in magnitude
and an angle right
that's the varying angles
okay so this list looks like this one
that's a position and a vector and then
we plot this and we have this vector
plot on the map and of course we are
using the new styling that our grid just
showed we can of course make different
settings here as Brad just showed but I
just want to show this example I'm
focusing now in India because you're
better plot also accepts geo vector a
and u objects so those are I mean this a
and U stands for east north up so so we
have a vector with three directions yeah
and I'm just showing a again a random
example showing those Victoria new
vectors are you vectors in the world
right
and the third kind of vector yeah there
is no not up here but we can say that
yeah probably
I I don't know but in the future we
could have a 3d version of Geo vector
plot right okay Joe vector X Y Z are the
same as jewelry on you we have okay
again we have something like this the X
and the y and z directions and we are
putting here I just random example okay
yesterday plot works the same way it
also accepts geo vectors D vector any an
you and give it to XYZ right so well
this doesn't need to have any change
right because Houston plot just shows
streams according to some vector fields
right so that's what we actually have
for just trim plot and I'm not showing
more examples showing director en you
and the vector X Y Z because it is the
same input right so let's go to some
applications say we have the positions
of of wind farms in the USA as you can
see those are points here and then we
can use these most histogram to see
where are the locations then we have
more so of course we have a lot of them
here right ok but now we can get the
directors for for the Queen's from you
from wind vector data in this case I'm
saying just get 200 randomly positions
in the USA and get the damn window
vector now right
I'm not going to abilities it sometimes
could take some time
ok I did that already and then we can
because this one returns us geo vector
object we can go directly to geo vector
plot and then have this this map with
vectors of course here I don't have the
new styling but we should try
I used abilities in an older version but
what we can do after having those balls
plots we can just combine them and show
the density of the wind farms and how
the vector winds are right again you can
here set different options you can set
you can make it more attractive anyway
but but it's important is that it's
possible to do it the last application I
have is geomagnetic magic Nick data I
mean we have the magnetic model data of
course I'm getting that anime getting
also a Joe vector object
now okay they want to describe this
input but we are essentially showing the
stream of the vectors of of magnetic
data at the North Pole
so we have yeah three different points
this one is called it North D Pole is
where exactly the Magnetic vector is say
totally vertical right this one is a
geographic pole the pole and this one is
a germinated North Pole it's like the
the one we we see when we see the world
with a big magnet on it and I think
that's about it
[Applause]